David Pollock ESPN College GameDay
analyst and game day is in Fort Worth
Texas it's number 11 Oregon and number
16 Auburn ducks and tigers will play ABC
Saturday Night Football David good
morning thanks for joining us what stood
out to you last night with Clemson and
Georgia Tech well I fell it first I've
ever seen then and I don't know if
you've ever seen it or not but I saw the
Georgia Tech football players actually
lifting weights on the sidelines in
pretty a more muffs is it too late for
them of that in it too late for that or
was it a party pump pump or not it
didn't work listen clemson is who we
thought they were and that's that that's
good news not Trevor Lawrence looks
somewhat human I would say but at the N
and the defense looks like they're going
to be ready to roll the atmosphere was
crazy so you know
listen it's never going to be the first
week are always kind of sloppy and look
in Miami Florida get lowered we saw that
a week ago that was super sloppy and
then last night Clemson wasn't at its
best but you can tell it's gonna be fun
to watch and I can't wait till over an
Oregon I think we're going to learn a
lot about SEC pac-12 and get the season
started everybody's feeling you told
last night looks sluggish a little bit
versus BYU and so I mean you feel those
bumps out in the beginning of these when
you get ready to roll things are really
very good what advice would you give
Trevor Lawrence this year I would I
would try to I would try to tell him
that I don't listen to everything and I
don't read everything and I don't look
at Twitter and I don't look at all the
Instagram and stuff like I would say
just stay away from people telling me
what I am because I can tell you as a
player when I started to have success
and I became an all-american and now you
read all the stuff that people are
saying and all the stuff that all the
all-american teams and the hyaline talk
and all that stuff what happens is you
have high expectations for yourself and
you want to put up numbers and I'll
never forget I want to get 20 facts like
that was my number and here's the thing
so now if I don't get it I'm failing and
I'm putting more pressure on myself I
mean all you
to worry about it being the best version
of you every single week studying trying
to keep everything in good perspective
and not look at down the road I'm not
saying it's easy Dan but you can't you
can't try to make the home run play nice
listen we saw to it last year go bonkers
go bananas in the beginning of season
and then then you saw him later season
it all he wanted to do is continue to
make big plays you know can't make the
highlight plays all the time and you got
to be ok with check downs and also I
would also tell them very assertively
when you run the football get down this
is it you get hurt we're screwed
ok make sure that that's clear too
and don't go after somebody if they
intercept your pass and Andrew Luck used
to do that all the time and we see where
Andrew Luck is I respect you more if you
don't try to make the tackle absolutely
not you throw interception you better go
make up 40 but you're crazy
all of those players somebody those
defensive players are just waiting to
blindside him pretty boy day every day
and everything we are taught in
defensive linemen when they throw an
interception find the quarterback in
thrill him and here's the thing
not drill him get him on the ground and
land on top of him with all of your
weight I love that laugh there I love
that be and you're right but that's why
I'm saying if you're on Trevor Lawrence
I throw a pick I just I roll over I go
into the fetal position that's it and
just wake me up ok what would be more
surprising the Patriots don't go to the
Super Bowl or Alabama's not playing in
the national title game
Patriots don't go to the Super Bowl I
would say I'm going to consider Alabama
obviously very much in that mix and
they're the team that looking Clinton
Alabama have proven you can go ahead and
put them there but I think Georgia's are
legit stumbling-block and if you're
looking at Alabama they've already got
three significant blows to their
linebackers little core one guy
transfers another guy tears me up
another guy the best guy Dillon those
Affairs is neat up so they're going to
be looking at like true freshman to
sophomore
or inside linebackers at the spot where
you got to communicate the most and so I
think that's something to keep an eye on
I know Alabama is going to be dominant
and they're going to be very much in the
mix for the Patriots come on it don't
matter who it is I mean you could we've
seen them do it with it doesn't even
matter Tom Brady got hurt and I still
made the playoffs for God's sake
you know Gert you get the goat with Bill
Belichick and I just think they've
they've got it figured out better than
everybody improving it I think I think I
would take that bet especially with some
of the injuries but I do expect them to
be there to give me one or two teams
that'll be outliers here that we might
not be looking at now but in December
you'll come back on and say I told you I
think Utah's one of those teams and I do
too hey yeah and I don't know if it's
good that we all are thinking you saw my
beef that might be a jinx were for Utah
but I think they're one of those teams
that has the ability to first of all it
starts with khalwat again he has not
left Utah all these years and he's been
really really good for a long long time
I mean maximizing all the talents that
they bring in 100% maximizes it and this
year I would say this is the most
talented team he's had I mean if you
look like night with Moss running the
football that dude he runs angry like he
runs he runs really mad and physical
when the offensive line will grow
they're young and inexperienced but
defensive line a bunch of guys stayed
for for their senior year so they didn't
have to but they would have been high
draft picks and they're eight and nine
deep on defense they're gonna have to
get the kicking game without you saw
that was an issue last night but I think
Utah's a team that 100% at the end of
the season we might be looking up and
going hey there there's a playoff
discussion because they're they're
scheduled to I think Dan London I mean
last night was one of their biggest
games of the teasing toilet top four
games they play Washington State USC in
Washington so if they find the way to
get those four wins I think everybody
else in their schedule they're going to
they're going to beat up pretty well
Washington's the caveat be listen I
think everybody most people are going to
have Clemson Alabama and Georgia like
that just it's going to be the three
teams that people are leaning on the
most because those three teams are by
far and away the most talented teams in
college football they have you go to
their practices and it just looks
different I mean they
got dudes all over the place their
deaths this is unbelievable so I think
those four teams are going to be in the
college football playoff finish this
sentence if Michigan doesn't improve
against their rivals Jim Harbaugh might
be looking for a job how about that I
mean because because Michigan played
well and had great moment but let's say
they don't beat Ohio State at Michigan
this year is that enough for Michigan to
move on from Jim Harbaugh you know
remember Michigan stopped before
hardball to go okay I mean they were
extremely relevant it was really really
really bad and now they're consistently
in the top ten towards the end of the
cities and they're always in the top 25
so the talent going out to the NFL has
been raised to a whole nother level if
you think about me Dan is the offense
for these guys like Jim Harbaugh is an
offensive genius that is what he is that
is who he is everywhere he's been he
we've had phenomenal offenses and you
know he hired a new OC this year with
data that comes in more shaped Patterson
friendly and going to run more RP O's
but John Brown has been carrying his
weight that was one of the best hires he
made and you've seen McAllen that kind
of a footballing defense will probably
take a little step back but they need to
find a way Jim Harbaugh need to find a
way to get his offense back to where he
had it when he had Kaepernick his
offense back when he had you know
Stanford players with Andrew Luck and
those guys that were the dominant cuz
the offense has been the weaknesses of
the game he's David Pollock ESPN college
football analyst College GameDay in Fort
Worth a head of the Oregon Auburn
matchup the artist formerly known as
Chip Kelly in the UCLA Bruins is this
gonna get worse before it gets better or
does it get better under Chip Kelly's
watch listen I I think if people are
expecting an organ resurgence I think
you're wrong I mean I I didn't think
that ever would happen again with Chip
Kelly regardless because listen he is
the perfect storm in eugene man he was
the first one with gps and tags and full
time nutritionist and the first one with
one of the first ones with up-tempo
when Nike was behind him but the great
uniforms and just it was a perfect storm
of everything and I just don't think
he's going to have that at UCLA or
anywhere else where he ever goes again
it was it was an awesome run for chicken
I think Chip Kelly's a great football
coach Chip Kelly's got to continue to
get dudes and better players and take
those players that maybe aren't those
higher caliber guys and turn him into
the Michael James's like he did Lord but
I think he's going to be really good at
UCLA when I say that I think he's going
to win eight or nine games yeah I get to
feeling excess I never have bought in
for more than that I'm not going to I
think if Kelly's good coach but the
recruiting aspect of Kelly will have to
improve and have to get better guys to
go get some of these other teams I had
Lynn Swann on the athletic director at
USC a couple of weeks ago and I said is
there a magic number that clay Helton
can keep his job I know that we want to
connect the dots with Urban Meyer but
how does clay Helton keep that job was a
nice issue and means you let her me like
he is just a great guy one of the great
guys in coaching but usc's culture now
is so different and when you watch their
offensive defensive lines the last
couple years man I'm just telling you as
a former defensive lineman it's not good
it needs the physicality and strength
and aggressiveness it needs to improve
just think about that although all the
years we've covered USC and all the
great quarterbacks and all the
unbelievable athletes like Reggie Bush
and all those guys from all that era and
now USC this year is running an air raid
offense I mean no errant offenses were
predicated on teams that have less
ability to find a way to beat teams with
more ability and run more plays and they
can dunk I mean usually the teams like
USC don't have to go to those form of
style so it's really interesting to
watch now with a transition for them but
it's it's got to get better USC cannot
be a team that doesn't go to ball games
they got to get more physical on a lot
of scrimmage and they got to get more
nasty to them so I I don't think
number and I think 80s will always tell
you the numbers game is always a little
bit different because what if I go B for
really really really good teams and I
lose through two really bad games you
know I mean that those are good and bad
pros and cons but it it's going to have
to change quickly for USC and I don't
know that it will but the offense of
that when you change your coordinators
there's nobody else to change then so
changing your OC after last year and if
it doesn't get fixed this year there's
not another guy that Lin swans gonna go
a are you gonna get a cat next the next
guy is usually the head guy I'll leave
you with this I'll give you your buying
stock you can buy stock and Trevor
Lawrence you can buy stock and Justin
Herbert buy stock and twoa
in the NFL Trevor Lawrence okay I'll
take I'll take Trevor Lawrence I've
never seen a kid Dan come into college
where I said he would be the number one
pick right now after his true freshman
year I've never I've never seen that in
my time doing this I mean he's he is the
legit 64 65 225 and and he's not Peyton
Manning and I'm saying that he's not
paid he's a statue in the pocket this
guy's a nationally I mean he's a 4 6
type act but he can run and he's got one
of the month by the way this is gonna be
the stupidest coming I may call that one
of the most impressive throws I saw
Trevor Lawrence make last night he was
running full speed in the first or first
quarter to his left full speed and
throws the ball on the run across his
body 20 yards over his wide receiver but
it ain't 55 yards
how am i unlike his talent his arm town
is already better than everybody else in
college football football are on par he
can move he's got touched and he can
throw guys open like he's got he's got
it all of us and you start comparing him
to Herbert Herbert Herbert you guys need
to make more free throws okay he misses
open guys consistently with accuracy
that drives you crazy and needs to
improve needs to get better to it he has
he has a lot of those Trevor Lawrence
qualities but it was six one six feet
tall and injury prone and it's not as
sick and not as big so I mean there
they're all good but I'll take Trevor
Lawrence don't you want to just somedays
hit Herbstreit the quarterback yes of
course who's the last who's the last
quarterback you hit Oh God
see Ben Roethlisberger the last
quarterback i sacked in a playoff game
in my rookie year before my second year
I broke my back so it's Ben
Roethlisberger and he's considerably
bigger than you yeah he always was like
he was like bringing down here in the
Rendon man you get it that was kind of
quarterbacks you got to go for the arm
so they can't throw it otherwise they're
gonna shrug off them and make you look
like a child David have fun this weekend
it's always great to talk to you we love
the enthusiasm thank you that's a David
Pollock ESPN college football analyst
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]